i've recently come across multiple 500
year old maps that are so interesting
yet so bizarre i cannot understand how
i've never seen or heard of these before
and i suspect by the end of this video
you'll likely feel the same because what
these maps show in the middle of the
sahara desert
is just not supposed to be there
now let me first primer your brain into
what you're about to see by sharing one
of the more unusual yet fascinating
discoveries made in just the last few
years in fact something that surprises
pretty much everyone when they hear it
for the first time which is the fact
that the sahara desert was a lush green
tropical paradise as recently as just 5
000 years ago in fact some sources
estimating as little as 4 500 years ago
before it rapidly transitioned to the
vast hot desert that we're all so
familiar with today consisting of
endless mountains of sand dunes that
span further than the eyes can see
a truly remarkable discovery considering
we had presumed for so long that the
sahara must surely have been millions of
years old and get this
not only was it a lush wetland full of
vegetation but it also had a massive
network of rivers in fact one of which
would rank among the world's largest
today but perhaps even more interesting
than that is the fact that in the middle
of the sahara desert was the world's
largest freshwater lake ever known to
have existed
so large in fact that this one lake had
50 percent more surface area than all
the north american great lakes combined
and all of this the rivers the lakes and
lush vegetation that made up the green
sahara disappeared in almost an instant
just a few thousand years ago
wild right but these figures of 4 500 or
5 000 years ago you see that's the part
where things start to get strange
for example take this little-known yet
incredible map from louis ii of france
which dates back to the year 1551.
there are so many aspects of this map
that are worthy of study and discussion
however let's focus a moment on the
sahara desert and notice that there are
inlets of water streaming into the
african continent from the north the
west and the south all along the
coastline
something that no longer exists today
but also notice the river that is
flowing into the middle of the sahara
what river is this supposed to be
exactly because surely it should not be
confused with the single river or the
senegal river excuse me which travels
east southeast into africa but nowhere
near as far east as this river is shown
to reach particularly as it's annotated
on other maps
take this one for example which is
another little-known map and was found
in atlas created by portuguese
cartographer diego hamem and also dates
to the mid 1500s and marks the same
massive river flowing all the way clear
through the middle of the desert into
the eastern sahara nearly reaching the
nile river and again let's not forget
the key detail here which is that this
is from nearly 500 years ago
which i mean come on where is this river
today and why have i never heard of it
before
and by the way when i point out that it
nearly reaches the nile river let's take
a look at yet another map and this one
was created in the year 1578
by gerard mercader certainly a name that
will ring a bell to far more people
however i'll venture to say that most
people are still unlikely to have ever
seen this before much less studied the
details annotated on this map which like
i mentioned a moment ago illustrates a
diverse river traveling through the
middle of the entire sahara until it
nearly reaches the nile
and by the way notice how it shows the
nile river extensively branching off in
various directions that also no longer
exist today i find that quite
interesting
but let me now point your attention to
the northern sahara and observe the
multiple rivers that seemingly flow
either into or from the mediterranean
sea
and notice that illustrates various
tribes cities or settlements that are
shown to have existed all along these
rivers and waterways
and while we're at it take a look at
another map this one is from 1645
created by petrus bertius that is based
on that same arcada map you just saw
now this image is obviously a bit blurry
but it still paints us a picture into
the nature of these mysterious river
systems but that's not all
take a look at this spectacular map that
was first published in the year 1639
by a claes johnson visher
certainly the image is also a bit blurry
like the other one when cropped but if
you look closely you can still see a
vast network of rivers traveling in
virtually every direction throughout the
sahara you know when i see these various
maps i can't help but be reminded of the
legends that claim that the nile river
once flowed from east to west because
let's look at this map here that was
created some 400 years ago in the early
1600s following the voyage of willem
shouten in the year 1619 after he was
the first to sail around cape horn
but notice how it shows the nile river
going further south again into
sub-saharan africa before it then turns
abruptly west
tell me that's not interesting because
it keeps bringing me back to the same
question which is
why have i never seen or heard of these
maps before and not only that why do
they show these particular or
spectacular rivers i should say in the
middle of the sahara desert as recently
as just four and five hundred years ago
a key detail that cannot be overstated
i mean since when is any of this
supposed to exist in the middle of the
sahara at that period of time and make
no mistake these rivers would certainly
have been an oasis for ancient human
civilizations that would have
undoubtedly occupied the lands around
them
i mean it's worth mentioning that there
are recent scientific studies that have
concluded exactly that which when you
think about it makes all the sense in
the world as human migration has long
been known to travel along rivers as
well as along coastlines where
settlements and entire civilizations are
then established
i've said it before and i'll say it
again the sahara desert has got to be
the hidden jackpot for lost ancient
human civilizations yet it receives
arguably the least amount of attention
not just from history enthusiasts but
from the archaeological community as
well in fact it's been said that much of
the sahara particularly the western
sahara remains literally and
figuratively almost blank as far as the
wider international research community
is concerned which i have to say is
incredibly unfortunate as evidence has
shown the existence of civilizations in
this region dating back more than 11 and
a half thousand years ago
so the question becomes
what is waiting to be discovered below
the endless sea of sand which could
potentially
be a preserve for archaeological
evidence dating back thousands of years
or perhaps far more recently as these
various century old maps seem to
indicate
honestly isn't it a bit weird that
you've never seen or heard of these maps
before i mean certainly there are some
people watching this that are familiar
with some of them but let's be real it's
not taught in school and without a doubt
a vast overwhelming percentage of the
masses have never seen or heard of these
before but to make things even more
bizarre than that these are just a few
of the ones that i've recently come
across in fact the most interesting map
of them all is 2 000 years old and it
shows something in the sahara desert
that is related to atlantis and that is
going to be the topic of my next video
in fact this video was going to include
all the above all these maps and the
topic of atlantis but there's so much to
unpack that i had to divide it into two
videos and i'll be honest and i know
people hate hype but that next video is
going to be quite interesting now that
said leave a comment and share what your
thoughts are on these maps that again
they show rivers and all kinds of things
happening in the sahara desert four and
five hundred years ago
that's not supposed to be there and
honestly it raises significant questions
and by the way if you're wondering why
you've never seen a herd of these before
it's because they sit in basements in
museums and never see the light of day
it's it's a tragedy actually so give
this video a thumbs up if you've never
seen or heard of these before or if you
found the content interesting and again
leave a a comment and share your
thoughts but i'm jimmy corsetti my
channel is called bright insight stay
tuned to my next video like i said is
going to be talking about atlantis
involving the sahara desert which i know
many people will find quite interesting
and also follow me on instagram and
support me and my channel on patreon
subscribe star or locals i'll have the
links down below but all of that said
i'll close it up again i'm jimmy my
channel is called bright insight and
stay tuned to another interesting video
real soon take care everybody